(somber music)
- This video
was going to be one
of my most favorite videos
that I've ever posted.
It is something that made me so happy,
but it also has brought me so much sadness
that I can't even really
put it into words.
It's been a few days.
And so this video is
basically showing you guys,
a kind of the story of
this hummingbird nest
that I found in my backyard.
And then fortunately, something happened
and just the babies
didn't survive and they,
my God.
I don't even like, I
hate talking about it.
But, I really wanted to share this video
with you guys because it is
something that made me so happy.
And so many of you were like
sharing this journey with me.
We were live streaming on Twitch.
I think we almost hit like 300 hours.
I kind of just like left you guys hanging
with this whole Twitch stream.
It was really traumatic,
because we had all had invested
so much time, and so much
heart, and so much love
into these little birds.
And then, you know, for
this tragedy to happen,
a lot of you may have never
had to deal with grief or loss
of a loved one, or a
friend, or pets or anything.
So grieving for some of you,
maybe something that is new.
So anything that you're
feeling it's totally normal.
It's confusing. Don't be afraid to cry.
Don't be afraid to ask for
help or talk to someone
and being able to do that.
And for us here to just kind of connect
and grieve together is something
that I think is very important.
And I just want you all to know,
that I love you guys so much,
and for just sharing
this beautiful journey
with all of us here online,
and I just want you to know
that Kiwi is still out there
and it just, is the most heartbreaking,
but also like the most beautiful thing
to just kind of still
go outside my backyard.
And she's still there.
(upbeat music)
So a little over a week ago, I
discovered a hummingbird nest
in my backyard, and I can't even tell you
how I felt when I found out,
like I actually started getting emotional.
I almost cried
because I've never seen a
hummingbird sit still before.
Not only that, there
were two eggs in there.
I was out of town
for about three weeks on a
road trip with my sister.
And when I came back, this
was here waiting for me.
And I started doing a live
stream over on Twitch.
And like at this point it's
been going for over a week.
We witnessed both of
the eggs hatching live.
When the first one hatched the first day,
we were all losing our minds.
And with a little bit of
research, the chat was like,
Hey, there's a really good chance
that this other egg is
going to hatch tomorrow.
So once the eggs are laid,
there's about a 13 to 17 day
period before they hatch.
So we found this nest at
people's perfect time ever.
Here she is behind me.
This is Kiwi and her two babies
which currently have not
been named at this point.
And what's really weird is,
I don't have
any like hummingbird
food or on a feeder.
Like there's nothing that I've
ever done to bring them here.
Now, after finding this nest,
I also found three others in my trees.
I feel like I have some sort
of weird wildlife sanctuary
that I didn't even know existed back here.
Wait, is that something else?
What's that right there?
That also looks like a potential other one
that has fallen off.
This is, so that's five!
How in the world do I have five
freaking hummingbird nests?
Like they must've been nesting here
for a very long time and
I didn't even know it.
Kiwi could have actually been born
in one of these nests, and now
she's back having her babies.
Oh my God, I'm gonna cry.
So the crazy thing is
anytime I come out here
and she flies away,
like I can spot her up here just watching.
So it's like, she know...
Oh there she is! She's over
there. She's over there.
She's over there. She's over there.
(mumbles)
She's over here.
Some may say, just either
you've losing your mind
and I'd say, maybe.
She's going to zip over here real soon.
There she is.
There she goes.
And that's, what's so crazy about this.
It's so hard to capture
a hummingbird on camera,
and the fact that she just sits here
and hangs out and feeds her babies.
And we've been watching her
for
almost
200 hours live on Twitch.
That's fascinating.
It's absolutely fascinating.
So here's the stream setup.
I'm streaming everything
off the Surface Book 3.
And this thing has been
on for over 200 plus hours
at this point.
I haven't even turned the screen off.
Like I've been pushing this little laptop
to its absolute limits.
It's connected with an Elgato capture card
which is going outside to my Sony A7S III,
with a 70 to 300 millimeter lens on.
Now, when I started this
I was using the A7 III
and it kept overheating.
And I didn't really want to put
my brand new A7S III out there
but I had to do it for the nest cam.
I'm also working on a
couple of upgrades for this.
I'm going to add a webcam here,
so I can do some live streaming
and live commentary over
top of the baby bird stream.
I'm going to be getting
a 600 millimeter lens
that I'm borrowing from Sony to be able
to really get in that nest.
Like I want it to feel
like we're inside of it.
And what's so weird is
watching this stream,
you can't really see how small
these birds actually are.
These birds weigh absolutely
nothing like the eggs
for almost like the size of tic-tacs.
It's crazy!
This bird has brought me so much joy.
Like I can't even explain it.
And it's so cool to be able
to share this with you,
and seeing all of the comments
in the chat has been so fun.
And I love that you guys are
also invested in this as well.
And I think today in this video
we're going to officially name
the babies. So stay tuned.
Let's open up that webcam,
and get this setup.
So here it is, it's USB, and
it has adaptive light sensor
1080p 60 frames a second.
It's also HDR enabled,
and nice wide angled lens
with an adjustable field of view, USB 3,
and flexible mounting options,
which is very important for,
you know, commentating
overtop of baby birds.
I love this flexible Mount
cause you can Mount this
to a tripod or you can
even just kind of set it
on the back of like your
monitor or your laptop.
Oh, this unscrews too.
So do you want to add this
just to a tripod stand alone?
You can do that, or you can
add the flexible Mount back on.
And there's also a little
tripod attachment here as well.
So many options.
Oh, it's got a little
lens cap too. That's nice.
Bird stream is about to evolve yet, again.
Let's go set it up.
(upbeat music)
About to (mumbles) the
webcam for the first time.
And this is so quick,
I plugged it in and it
auto- installed, auto-recognized.
And then I downloaded
the Razer Synapse app,
which will let me get some
more in-depth controls
with this camera, but
really I don't need it.
I just added it into Streamlabs,
and we're ready to go.
We're now going to name the babies live.
I have a few duo names
right now,
but we need
two more duo names.
Web cam here test.
Oh my God. (mumbles)
And they're getting fed.
They're feeding, they're feeding,
they're feeding, they're feeding.
Oh,
feed the back one.
The back one needs fed.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're getting your meal.
Have your meal.
Hi, guys welcome to the stream.
So, I'm actually recording
a YouTube video right now.
We need two more duo names.
You guys keep saying Yerba and
Matte, but that's like, so...
It's so obvious.
You know Kahlua and Cream,
that's cute. Egg and other egg.
(laughs loudly)
That's it, egg and other egg.
You got to get the pool all set up.
So guys, this is a very big moment.
The babies are going to get their name.
What do we name the babies?
Frappe
and Chino,
Mochi and
Macha,
Coffee bean,
(laughs loudly)
Dude, that's my vote.
Lemon and lime, and
(laughs loudly)
and egg and other egg.
Here we go.
I'm voting Coffee bean and Tea leaf.
Not to like sway your
votes. (sad piano music)
Coffee bean and Tea leaf
is very close to my heart.
Oh my gosh, Emily is here!
She has just raided the
channel with 12 viewers.
Hi, Emily.
I think lemon and lime are
winning right now. Shoot.
I've only got a few more minutes left.
(mumbles) voter fraud.
(laughs loudly)
The bill and ballots here.
It's just, you know, suggestions.
Stop the count.
Someone is suing for defamation
of the lemon and lime name.
History repeats again.
Oh,
my gosh.
We stole the voting.
(laughs loudly)
I'm losing my mind.
Oh, this is, the suspense
is, is actually killing me.
I am going to go to Coffee Bean
and Tea Leaf after this event wins.
And we have ourselves a
winner! Ladies and Gentlemen,
Coffee bean and Tea leaf,
has won! (laughs loudly)
Kiwi, named your babies
Coffee bean and Tea leaf.
Well, I guess I'm going to go
to Coffee Bean Tea Leaf now.
How do you guys feel?
(somber piano music)
It's closed.
I used to drink my latte's here.
I sit by the fire and enjoy it.
But now, there's no enjoying.
So, it looks like my favorite
Coffee Bean and Tea Leaf is closed.
Guess the baby names are now a tribute.
Let's go find another one
that might actually be open.
(upbeat music)
So we're going to be approaching
a Coffee Bean and Tea Leaf,
that appears to be open.
There's a sign that says we're open.
(upbeat music)
This one's for you Kiwi, and Coffee bean
and Tea leaf babies.
It's here, It's here, It's
here, It's here, It's here,
It's here, It's here, It's here.
(unboxing suitcase)
Oh,
what
have we here?
Hey Justine, is this necessary?
Absolutely.
This is my life.
All right, little guys.
We have got something for you.
Had to shut the stream
down. It's quite tragic.
So we're, we're dark for a minute.
This might be the biggest lens I've had
on this camera, because in
what world do I ever need,
A 600 millimeter?
Which world is that?
Is it this one?
(upbeat music)
Oh my gosh, we are so
freaking close to this nest.
You guys, you all lose your minds.
So look at the difference
between the 300 to the 600.
Unbelievable.
(upbeat music)
The quality of this lens is unbelievable.
Like I can actually see the
feathers on these babies.
Like I can, the detail.
It's just,
overwhelming.
(upbeat music)
There's apparently like
hummingbird hats that you
can wear when they will
like feast out of your hat.
This is new information to me.
I made this little note.
It's a little bit weathered at this point,
but I made this for the gardener
because I didn't want them
to do any sort of gardening
on my fake grass that may
potentially disturb the babes.
Cheers.
(melancholy orchestral music)
I'm so sad. I have to
end this video this way.
(cries loudly)
This is (mumbles) that I
was so afraid of happening,
and it did. I can't even walk outside.
Something not (mumbles) last night.
And unfortunately the
babies, they didn't make it.
There's a clip of it on Twitch.
Yes. I think something just cut up
either chopped down the
branch, and knocked it down.
God, I hate it. (crying continues)
(melancholy orchestral music)
(melancholy piano music)
It's been like such a traumatizing week,
but coming out here and
still seeing Kiwi fly around
and,
we might've spotted her with a boy.
Hi, Kiwi.
Oh my baby, oh I'm so happy to see her.
It warms my heart.
Like just seeing her still here.
She hasn't left.
She hasn't given up and
just kind of seeing her
move on,
has sort of helped me move on.
Like I know,
that some people apparently like,
This is crazy.
How are you so invested in these birds?
I don't know, honestly, like
they, they captured my heart.
They captured all of your guys' hearts
here on the internet.
And I just love to show you guys Kiwi,
and show you that she's doing
well and she's still here.
And we've seen her
flying around with a boy,
and I think she might be
looking for a new place to nest.
So Kiwi, I think has moved on.
I'm sure she's grieving as all of us have.
It's definitely has
been a very tough week.
I'm not going to lie.
It's just like trying to process it
and not sure if I should share
it with you guys or anything
but this video was so beautiful
and it was so special to me.
So I'm so glad that you guys were able
to come along for this journey
and share Kiwi and her babies.
And maybe, just maybe,
we'll have another nest.
And I will protect that
nest with my own life.
(melancholy piano music)